Sonic Superstars is playable here at
Summer game Fest and we got hands on
with the short demo that was available
now Jean Loop and give me your initial
impressions of Sonic Superstars so we
gotta play two stages uh the first is
like the not Green Hill Zone and then
the second one's like a jungle stage uh
I played as Sonic and it plays Amy uh
Sonic plays like Sonic sure does Amy
plays like Amy she's got the hammer it's
a classic Amy uh her classic design
which I love from Sonic CD and I mean
yeah I think the big question people had
is like does this feel like Classic
Sonic because I mean immediately like it
doesn't feel maybe as special because we
already had Sonic Mania but to be fair
like this is not made by the Sonic Mania
team so I think the question was like
can this team also kind of capture that
classic magic and I would say the answer
is yes like it definitely like you know
I think it has all the Staples of uh
classic 2D Sonic the stages felt very
expansive just the brief time went
through it I was like wow like there's
some like levels of like layers and
verticality
um to it that it felt felt very large
but I mean yeah like all the stuff's
there they had the uh the Chaos Emerald
stages uh which is like this weird
um 3D you're like grapple hooking to try
and like catch the Chaos Emerald which I
I thought was kind of fun and just like
a little neat diversion but what's
interesting is when you get the Chaos
Emerald you then unlock a power like the
first stage of Sonic I unlocked the
ability you unlock water and then you
can turn into like a little like
gelatinous water version of uh Sonic and
then that allows you to like go up a
waterfall and and it seems kind of based
on like this just essentially just opens
up like a alternate path that you can go
around
um the other option uh I got was like
decoy attacks where you can send like
copies of yourself on screen
um to fight enemies which I had as Amy
and it looked really goofy or like just
like 2080s just go like flying on the
stage and hit everyone and uh I thought
that was like funny um so yeah it seems
like they're kind of mixing a
combination of this is for traversal
versus this is for like dealing with
enemies
um as far as how those like impact your
overall feel of the game they did feel
kind of limited because you would just
like activate them and they would be
available for like 30 seconds and then
uh they'd go away and then they were on
like a cooldown so you couldn't use it
for a while it's kind of be like
deliberate when you used it
um
but like otherwise it's just like yep
there sure is 2D Sonic and if you like
2D Sonic I think you're gonna be real
happy and if you don't like 2D Sonic
like this is
who's been a producer on the Sonic
series for a very long time and that's
basically what he told me was that you
know Sonic Frontiers is a modern
interpretation of Sonic in a 3D World
sure whereas Superstars what they're
trying to do is channel that same energy
from Sonic Mania and you know Sonic
Mania was a great game on its own and it
also had that old school pixel art that
retro style that everyone kind of fell
in love with Through The Years with
Sonic so not only is Superstars modern
in the graphical sense because they are
using like actual 3D models sure more
modern art style with that along being a
2d uh Adventure game but it's also the
chaos the or the emerald powers that you
mentioned opening up different parts of
the stages and I think that's the most
impressive part from the demo that we
saw was that just how expansive those
are because you are going like you got
to go right right it's yeah I'll make it
to the boss uh fight the boss but I
noticed especially in the jungle stage
that you mentioned there are there's so
much to explore there's there's so many
avenues that I saw and thought like okay
on my second run maybe I'll try to go
all the way up and I've almost forgot
that I had the power that waterfall
power yeah that just opens up a totally
different part of the level that you
don't see so I do think that there
there's something more there than just
being like oh we're slapping modern
Graphics Entre traditional Sonic so that
that's that's promising but again I
think the quirks of Sonic uh still very
much show through some of the boss
battles were fun I like the mechanics
which they were showing but at the same
time you know
it's uh you know it's not like you're
going to be playing a Mario Odyssey
being a you know this big jump for the
series I would kind of equate it to like
the way uh Nintendo has done this in a
while but like I feel like I'm a Wii
they kind of did the thing where you had
like you'd have like your you know big
3D like Mario Galaxy but then you'd have
like new Super Mario Brothers which was
just like classic 2D Mario and like this
feels like that's what they're doing
with Superstars as like a compliment to
exactly you know Frontiers like you said
and I do like that like that is I think
a good path for Sonic as a franchise to
take and that's what ezago mentioned
like this isn't supposed to be like the
the flagship uh entry like they have
Frontiers they have Superstars so they
have like this dual track to kind of I
guess please Sonic fans in uh different
ways with uh what they're doing with the
series so uh but yeah it was it was a
fairly short demo but I do want to bring
up uh Co-op sure which we didn't we
didn't necessarily get Hands-On with but
I did talk to izuga about how that works
so this is the first Sonic game I
believe with four player co-op I'm not
sure how it's going to work in terms of
because like Sonic can go fast and he's
going to be ripping through those stages
but yeah he's like a tether system to
make sure that everyone kind of stays
together
um
yeah yeah but I I do like you mentioned
playing Amy and then Knuckles and Tails
also have their traditional Powers so
they're not doing not necessarily like
revamping any of the characters they're
gonna do the things that you know and
love about them uh throughout the stages
so but yeah I mean it sure is Sonic and
I hope that like the people looking for
that thing are going to find what
they're looking for in this game exactly
yes so those are our impressions of
Sonic Superstars which you can expect
this fall on all the major platforms and
if you want to learn more about Sonic
Superstars stick with GameSpot